2022's Elvis was apparently the only
movie about her father that Lisa Marie
Presley could watch but how did the
director feel about her the Unexpected
death of Lisa Marie Presley on January
12 2023 at the age of 54 after a brief
hospitalization has shocked the world
celebrities and ordinary fans have
joined together to mourn her last people
all over the world followed her music
career which followed in the footsteps
of her father legendary actor and
musician Elvis Presley she's remembered
fondly by those who were touched by her
Artistry and for the way she carried her
family name with dignity and Grace for
many years in the harsh public eye even
those who spent time with her recently
seemed to be stunned by her sudden
passing after all Lisa Marie had
attended the golden Global Wars with her
mother Priscilla just days before her
death one of those people who was
clearly affected by Presley's And Timely
lost as director baz luhrmann who
directed 2022's Elvis Lisa Marie Presley
publicly supported and endorsed lemon's
biopic highly complementing the
performances and the film overall after
seeing it Presley and lemon both
attended the 2023 Golden Globe ceremony
and was seated together with Austin
Butler who took home the award for best
actor for his portrayal of Elvis Presley
in the film in the wake of Lisa Marie
Presley's death verman seems to be just
as devastated as the rest of the world
his moving tribute to her gives the
world a snapshot of the sort of person
Presley seems to have been at heart in
an Instagram message posted on January
13th Bas lemon paid tribute to his
friendship with Lisa Marie Presley using
a picture of Presley sharing a laugh
with Austin Butler during the Elvis
media tour in 2022 lemon wrote over the
last year the entire Elvis movie family
and I have felt the privilege of Lisa
Marie's kind Embrace her sudden shocking
loss has devastated people all around
the world I know her fans everywhere
join me in Sharing prayers of love and
support for her mother Priscilla and her
wonderful daughters Riley Finley and
harbor Lisa Marie we will miss your
warmth your smile your love Presley was
indeed quite supportive of Elvis perhaps
surprisingly so it seems that lemon's
film worked as magic over her in a way
that other Elvis related films didn't
perhaps the strength of Butler's
performance helped gain her trust after
its release even though she wasn't
involved with the film's production he
honored him in every way possible that
you could possibly honor him speaking
during a post-screening q a posted in
June of 2022 Presley admitted that she'd
approached lemon's take on the story
with trepidation and was nervous to see
the whole movie She summed up her
experience of watching biopex related to
her father as a Tense one admitting in
my life it's been one disappointment
after the other in terms of people
portraying my father in various films
she later described the efforts of the
many actors who have tried to replicate
her father's mannerisms with the Todd's
southernism bless their hearts
thank you
but she said Butler's work proved to be
the exception to the many performances
she had witnessed before saying at this
point I tell you this with all my heart
and that's the only reason that I'm here
it's been done right